quebec is well known as the
french-speaking part of canada but
before it was a part of the land of
maple leaf it was a part of british
north america and before that new france
hence its settlement in the 17th century
by french speakers who became the
quebecois of today but given the former
british control and their past animosity
with the french why didn't france ever
try to retake quebec for itself why did
they just leave it to their rival so
france controlled quebec from its first
settlement there in the early 17th
century to 1763 and this was the year
that france accepted defeat in the seven
years war named so because it lasted for
nine years as a result of that defeat
britain took all of france's land east
of the mississippi in order to
consolidate its control over north
america and give its loyal colonists
there who were loyal room to expand
westward some stuff happened and it
wasn't long until british north america
saw a rebellion which led to the
creation of the united states of america
during the american revolutionary war
the french got involved and given
britain's defeat in 1783 why didn't they
try to regain their lost land from 20
years prior well there were several
reasons the first was the occupying
territory made it much easier to claim
and britain still held quebec and also
in a war that doesn't end in one side's
occupation you can't demand everything
and what france had pushed to gain was
tobago because sugar plantations make
all of the money unlike quebec which
just exported fur the second reason was
that france had largely got what it
wanted and that it wanted to aid the us
to make britain economically weaker and
that had been achieved there was no
sense in pushing too hard and forcing
britain to keep fighting which would
have been expensive which brings us to
the third reason money france was mostly
broke at this point and re-establishing
imperial control over a colony that
wasn't very lucrative in the first place
was quite expensive so what about after
this as you know the american revolution
wasn't britain and france's last war
since the french revolution and the
subsequent napoleoning of europe meant
that there was plenty of war to be had
france however despite napoleon's many
victories wasn't in a position to invade
north america because the royal navy was
blocking the way and also napoleon
didn't want to upset the united states
and so with this knowledge better plan
sell louisiana to them and use the money
to fight and defeat his many enemies and
after napoleon's eventual defeat there
was no more wars between britain and
france so gaining quebec that way
wouldn't be possible furthermore as time
went on quebecois and french culture
diverged and the connection between the
two became weaker for example during
world war one the quebecois opposed
conscription since they had no loyalty
to either the british empire or their
french ally and as a result over time
both sides ceased to see each other as
the same people but as sort of cousins
that's not to say that france had no
interest in the area in the 1960s
independence for quebec became a major
political issue in canada and the french
followed it closely infamously this
period saw french president charles de
gaulle shout long liver free quebec
during his visit to montreal this
shockingly caused a diplomatic incident
and de gaulle immediately left for
france after this most french leaders
took the position of not officially
taking her starts but closely following
quebec independence movements but that
said despite taking an interest there
was zero desire for quebec to join
france on both sides too much time had
passed and france had missed her chance
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bisonette
kelly moneymaker corso wolff jordan
longley adam stalter jerry lamdan marcus
arsenault wyan hockey spencer lightfoot
words about books podcast gustav swan
captain cydog roddy martin common yoon
boogerly wiggly misses it marvin cassow
aaron the white matthew shipley alex
schwinn maggie patzkowski anthony
beckett maxon flaudio the mcwhopper
corey turner spinning three plates
copper tone winston caywood charles the
first and scottish trekkie